[Musique]
c'est un souvenir belleville aujourd'hui
je crois oui oui c'est un souvenir parce
que il reste pas grand chose des anciens
belleville on l'a pincé les immeubles
c'était quelquefois nécessaire
on a l'art construit d'autres et puis
les gens aussi ont changé et gicm ans il
change la bière 100 da revient et puis
l'homme aussi l'homme s'est en allé
et puis les revenus mais d'autres sont
revenus à coups de postes et de zac les
immeubles neufs de verre et de béton ont
engendré les nouveaux habitants de
belleville le kiosque de la place des
fêtes n'en revient pas comme l'a dit le
bottier à belleville tout a changé
[Applaudissements]
vous avez l'impression d'habiter dans un
vrai quartier bénigne pas forcément
bellerive mais dans un quartier de paris
les gens du quartier vivent à belleville
où il va y arriver à paris dans le 20e
par exemple écoutez je ne sais pas trop
peut-être certains gift il avait lille
c'est fini c'est une une perception un
peu personnel je pense vous vous lavez
cette perception de la ville aujourd'hui
non parce que ma famille habite et
belleville longtemps et c'était un autre
ville et j'ai connu ce quartier il n'y
avait pas de tour et vous souhaitez
autre chose
c'est sur la partie 19e arrondissement
de belleville que les tours ont poussé
c'est là aussi que depuis deux ou trois
ans tout près du boulevard belleville
s'est installée la deuxième communauté
asiatique de paris
traditionnellement implantés dans le
xiiie arrondissement des cambodgiens et
des vietnamiens sont venus à belleville
d'abord parce qu'il y avait des
logements neufs ensuite parce que les
loyers y étaient moins chers pour les
bellevillois un quartier chinois est née
elle est important de la communauté
asiatique ici oui
belleville et un nouveau quartier pour
les asiatiques de paris normalement
c'est à 13e et maintenant ils disent là
aussi ça commence
comment se fait-il que partout il ya les
restaurants ça commence très les
restaurants les boutiques tout ça et ça
va vous êtes bien accepté dans le
quartier vous êtes bien implanté oui je
trouve les affaires marchent bien
ouais un peu ça veut dire moyens
belleville qu'est ce que c'est pour vous
d ati gorille en internat et aux bons
mots grecs tous les commerces qui sont
en vente ils sont achetés par des
sociétés
d'après bon mais quand tu sais ça dépend
surtout des restaurants qu'il installait
produits d alimentation comme ici car
c'est un marchand de meubles et
maintenance et initiatique alors mettre
les ordures devant la porte de la
marchandise est vous avez l'impression
qu'il arrive de plus en plus
d'asiatiques dans le quartier c'est à
dire oui c'est vrai qu'un commerçant
banques parce qu'ils s'asseyent payent
plus cher et paris et il habite dans
l'est dans les étages là dans l'immeuble
oui mais vis à vis de nous en avons
beaucoup dans l'immeuble mais ça ne pose
pas de problème la communauté nationale
ont facilement via les problèmes qu'ils
aillent est où la marchandise se la
mettre sur le trottoir et après tout les
ordures jonchent le trottoir
l'arrivée de cette communauté asiatique
quelque peu bousculé plus dans leur tête
que dans leur vie quotidienne les
habitudes des vieux bellevillois et moi
je prédis dans 20 ans dit si belle ville
de couleur jaune voiliers et ça c'est
dramatique parce qu' on essaie bombe à
ces gens ils vont là où ils peuvent
c'est possible mais dans le fond c'est
que c'est la fin d'une manière de vie
c'est la fin d'une culture chez nous à
belleville on avait nous avions nous
notre culture notre manière de parler de
nous exprimer de vivre tout ça tout ça
c'est fini c'est foutu à la ronde et moi
le canard laqué pour ma part j'en suis
belle ville a toujours été une terre
d'accueil pour les étrangers aujourd'hui
pour les asiatiques mais dès le début du
siècle des vagues successives de
migrants sont venus s'y installer les
communautés étrangères qui vivent dans
belleville voulait percevez comment vos
vieux bellevillois allons écouter
en principe il ya deux choses vous avez
les anciennes communautés qui venait
d'ailleurs comme nous expliquait il y
avait l'arménienne la grecque et la
juive alors nous n'avons pas remarqué de
xénophobie que ces gens là parce que ces
gens là ont surtout apporté le courage
se sont mis à travailler nous ont donné
même un certain exemple des gens qui
n'avaient rien se sont installés en
travail et ont fait leur place et non un
bété personnes et nous apporter
techniquement beaucoup de choses il y
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il ya de
nouvelles communautés qui viennent je ne
peux rien en dire je ne les connais pas
mais j'imagine que ces gens-là
n'apportent rien ou alors des choses
négatives parce que ils s'approchent à
grand chose et peut alors leur
descendance au lieu de deux se mettent
au travail de s'instruire essayer de sa
cible et ça n'existe pas c'est du
racisme
non c'est pas du racisme c'est peut-être
une certaine hostilité
mais c'est surtout une constatation
qu'on ne peut pas dire que nous sommes
des racistes peut pas l'être moi non
plus non absolument pas 1918 arrivée des
arméniens à belleville 1920 des grecs
1933 une communauté israélite chasser
d'allemagne par le nazisme et puis dans
les années 50 et 60 belleville est
devenu un bout d'afrique du nord
toutes ces communautés ont marqué et
marquent encore la vie du quartier
de par leur présence économique mais
également de par leurs coutumes il ya
beaucoup de commerçants musulmans dans
le quartier s'est mélangé en israël
était musulman il n'y a pas de problème
entre les communautés n'ont pour
l'instant dans le calcio les acquis et
les affaires marchent bien ramponneau la
sas calmement
pourquoi là vraiment c'est calme parce
que ça va des mots liés un peu partout
et puis j'ai pas les gens ils ont peur
de descendre dans le quartier pour les
chambres de venir à cause de la drogue
je pourrais je ne sais pas parce que de
temps en temps réel et flic est à
présent temps alors rigolé flic expert
les jambes c'est pas la changer
mais c'est fini maintenant c'est le
centre de l'attroupement mézières avant
c'était bienvenu non ce qui ne vous tue
pas on croit vraiment être encore
présent mais non ici dans cet été en
fait 5 ou le quartier de la drogue à
belleville c'est la rue ramponeau le
boulevard de belleville et la rue delory
ion le soir entre 19 et 23 heures
les marchands d'héroïne sont là la
drogue est souvent caché dans un trou de
murs dans un couloir d'immeubles ou sous
un escalier ou alors méthode plus
subtile
le vendeur mais la drogue dans un paquet
de cigarettes vides posé par terre à ses
pieds le client arrive donne d'abord
l'argent le vendeur s'en va le client se
baisse et ramasse le paquet conséquences
en cas d'intervention de la police le
dealer n'a jamais de drogue sur lui et
puis toujours dans cette zone subsiste
le difficile problème d atelier
clandestin de confection dans des
immeubles délabrés où les murs menace de
s'écrouler à tout moment des turcs sans
papiers travaillent et vivent sur place
une machine à coudre un transistor et
une paillasse pour dormir toute la
semaine samedi et dimanche compris
il fabrique des robes et des pantalons
[Musique]
la zone buisson pali kao
ici c'est le belleville éventrée
al'approche de l'hiver les petits
yougoslave viennent sur les terrains
vagues chercher du bois pour faire du
feu dans le poil de l'unique pièce vie
toute la famille en ramasse le moindre
morceau car il fait froid dans ces
immeubles parfois sur un mur les traces
d'un passé qui n'est pas si lointain au
dessus des fenêtres murées après une
expulsion
un peu plus loin on a déjà rasé
seuls les pavés rappelles tu encore la
rue
quant aux immeubles restants ils
attendent pour les semaines à venir
l'arrivée de la pelleteuse et du
bulldozer
[Musique]
d'ici là une des radios libres du
quartier s'y est installé elle s'adresse
aux africains et aux antillais de
belleville pilipili d'après les
animateurs ça ne marche pas trop mal
belleville c'est aussi le quartier des
squats
beaucoup ont disparu parfois dans des
conditions violentes rue de l'est par
exemple aujourd'hui ceux qui restent
sont tranquilles disent les riverains
les squats du 20e
c'étaient les durs ceux où le drapeau
d'action directe flotter aux fenêtres ce
aussi où les opérations de police ont
été les plus nombreux
[Musique]
en france ou à l'étranger
tu as les algériens talent et noir on ne
dit rien les blues et le notaire bord on
l'appelle à ce goûter gabrion il existe
encore un coeur du vieux belleville il
bat quelque part près de la rue des
pyrénées et d'églises du jourdain ici on
vit encore dans le village d
bellevillois sait comment un
bellevillois c'est le monsieur qui a
vécu l'ère qui sait plus où il a vécu et
puis c'est tout bien tempérament oui il
ya un certain tempérament il ya eu il ya
une mentalité bellevilloise laquelle
mentalité disons d'amitié de bons
rapports entre les uns et les autres
je parle pour les couches anciennes
c'est une manière de vivre
oui vraisemblablement parce que lorsque
ces gens là se rencontrent dans la rue
il ya toujours un petit salut discret et
même si on ne se parle pas on ne
s'ignorent pas dans la tête de tout un
chacun et à l'autre sont eux qui ont
transformé le quartier de cette manière
on se voit dans la rue on se dit bonjour
tu vois ça ne suffit pas les rapports ne
s'arrête pas là le café c'est un lieu de
réunion c'est une bourse où on se
retrouve presque en famille vous y allez
vous bien sûr tous les jours tous les
jours hui tous les jours il ya un petit
café on prend le café
après déjeuner à l'occasion entre camara
nous allons dans la matinée également
ça nous fait un petit moment de détente
la rue de belleville c'est là que tous
se retrouvent parce que dans le quartier
c'est l'artère celle qui fait vivre et
celle dont on ne peut se passer
et puis derrière une porte parfois se
cache le passé une cour avec des fleurs
voire même ce que les bellevillois
appelle une forêt ces endroits
ils sont rares à belleville et on n'aime
pas tellement les montrer ils font
partie des jardins secrets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
belleville dans vingt ans vous le voyez
comment bah oui mais c'est à vous avez
eu lui sur l'avenir suis pas devin mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on va tout casser
ses vieilles maisons et puis bah vous
aurez des huiles dit un petit peu de
gazon par ci par là quelques arbustes
ce sera à peu près tout des gens qui
signeront qui ne se salueront même plus
qui penseront à leurs affaires à leur
histoire à leurs problèmes puis c'est
tout voilà ça sera un tout autre monde
c'est sa plus belle ligne
vraisemblablement non valeur un jour je
quitterais belleville oui bien sûr oh
oui d'ici peu peut-être dans six mois un
an oui c'est sûr je ne peux plus me on a
eu une super c'est moi oui c'est sûr
[Musique]
où
l'anonymat existe dans ces tours
aujourd'hui pour certains oui bien sûr
mais c'est encore quelque chose de tout
à fait personnel je connais beaucoup de
gens dans mon immeuble beaucoup de gens
le connaissent on a plein de relation
ensemble
elle m'avait dit j'ai vaincu le béton or
on a vaincu le béton oui mais qu'on a
une fille dès qu'on a des relations
humaines dès qu'on a créé des liens
quelque part le béton appelée
l'importance au fait vous l'avez compris
le belleville nouveau est arrivé
[Musique]
e